freuen wir uns nun auf eine weitere
folge unserer beliebten serie
vielen dank auch jetzt versucht uns die
heute show auch noch weihnachten genau
in diesem sinne meine damen und herren
lassen sie uns mal über obdachlosigkeit
sprechen ja ich weiß hat keinen bock
drauf das thema versaut die feststimmung
und es macht angst
in zeiten explodierender mieten fragen
sie inzwischen viele könnte mich das
auch eines tages erwischen man schätzt
dass bei uns in deutschland 52.000
menschen auf der straße leben plus
wahrscheinlich über eine million
sogenannte wohnungslose die zb bei
bekannten unterschlüpfen
genau wissen wir das leider nicht denn
dazu müsste man keine ahnung nachzählen
man weiß statistisch alles wie viele
bergziegen und wie viele zwerghasen es
in deutschland gibt aber wie viele
menschen ohne wohnung da stehen weiß man
nicht ja ist übrigens das erste mal dass
in der heute show um ziegen geht und es
hat nichts mit dem türkischen
präsidenten zu tun ist aber eine völlig
andere geschichte gemacht haben
[Applaus]
wir kommen und gehen ab obdachlosigkeit
das ist sichtbare armut bei der wir uns
gerne sagen die penner sind doch selber
schuld
ja aber damit macht man es sich ein
bisschen zu einfach klar oft sind die
persönliche tragödien und drogensucht im
spiel aber natürlich hat es inzwischen
auch mit wohnungsmangel zu tun
mietwucher allein in berlin haben sich
die mieten in den letzten zehn jahren
quasi verdoppelt deswegen sagt ja dieser
linke sozialromantiker völlig zu recht
wir müssen dabei davon ausgehend von
einem normalen durchschnittsverdiener
von einem vielleicht auch ein verdiener
haushalt der muss es sich auch leisten
können in den großen städten in
deutschland noch zu wohnen wenn das
nicht mehr der fall ist dann haben wir
ein ernsthaftes problem
friedrich wir haben ein ernsthaftes
problem jetzt
wobei wenn er wie er sagt dann meint er
natürlich ihr denn seine firma blackrock
er bleibt ja im aufsichtsrat ist
anteilseigner von wo novia und deutsche
wohnen den gehören 700.000 mietwohnung
und genau diese firmen haben mit
modernisierung und anschließender
mieterhöhung mit dafür gesorgt dass sich
normalverdiener deutsche innenstädte
nicht mehr leisten können hier jetzt
nicht im heute-show fanshop der wo novia
adventskalender
da wird tatsächlich jeden tag ein schoko
nikolaus aus seiner wohnung raus geklagt
weil er sich die sanierte kurze nicht
mehr leisten kann
das geht den ganzen dezember so und am
schmeißt man dann sogar maria josef und
das jesuskind raus und vergesst eure
scheiße esel nicht mit nokia zieht doch
nach bethlehem
die faustregel lautet wenn man mehr als
30 prozent des netto einkommens für
miete zahlt dann wird's eng
inzwischen geben rund 40 prozent der
deutschen mieter mehr aus stand heute
gleichzeitig haben unsere städte über
jahre sozialwohnungen verkauft der trend
ist klar auch arbeitende menschen können
sich irgendwann das wohl schlicht nicht
mehr leisten und im fernsehen gibt es
sogar schon ein völlig neues genre
reporter spielen obdachlos mein name ist
das disney
und ich bin ab heute obdachlos mir ist
und sich frisch gehört jetzt schon kalt
das ist echt schweinekalt bereits nach
wenigen stunden muss christoph abbrechen
würde irgendwo rein gehen in der kälte
zu können ist nicht schön
hört doch auf ist gar nicht schön gut
dass ihr das endlich mal bewiesen hat
gerade mal ein paar stunden hat der sat1
penner durchgehalten dann ist er weint
bei starbucks zusammengebrochen hier
jetzt sogar als jochen schweizer
gutschein die erlebnis doppelstunde
obdachlosigkeit powered by emotion meine
damen und herren in dortmund haben sie
bis neulich übrigens knöllchen verteilt
an obdachlose und in ungarn ist
obdachlos sein offiziell ein verbrechen
auch eine art das problem anzugehen
immerhin kümmern sich bei uns in
deutschland kirchen und private helfer
wie zum beispiel ärzte gleichzeitig sagt
die stadt berlin sollen doch unsere
verkehrsbetriebe ihre u bahnhöfe zu
schlafsälen machen
der senat sieht die bvg der
verantwortung sehen sie das als zumutung
an sag mal so wie ich sehe wir sehen uns
in der verantwortung menschen von a nach
b zu bringen und das möglichst schnell
und möglichst pünktlich und möglichst
ohne ohne stress und ärger und nicht mal
das können wir zur wahrheit gehört
allerdings auch nicht nur der staat nein
auch wir bürger haben die eindeutige
tendenz das ganze thema zu verdrängen
gerade in dieser jahreszeit
wenn es knossalla ist gründer der
initiative unsere weihnachten soll
schöner werden
er macht sich sorgen um die
besinnlichste zeit des jahres jaja meine
frau ich will lieben ja weihnachtsmärkte
allein in dieser geruch dieser einmalige
mischung aus frittierfett bienenwachs
unterbrochen
hast du das sonst oder diese nähe wenn
sich wildfremde menschen an dir vorbei
quetschen ich sag immer besser als gar
keins setzt hier irgendwas geschwitzt
aus dem erzgebirge und merkt schon auf
nachhauseweg also diesen dort hässlichen
scheiße feier wird die für gar nichts
gebraucht
[Musik]
es könnte so großartig sein aber leider
gibt es da ein problem was mir wirklich
den kern des fest also das shopping
verhagelt obdachlose wir können ja
nichts dafür aber wie soll ich meine
champignons und knoblauch flotten
genießen wenn neben mir sitzt er mir
immer ein schlechtes gewissen machen
deshalb meine aktion unter weihnachten
soll schöner werden - als geniale idee
die es nach lösen werden mit wenigen
handgriffen zu einem teil des weihnachts
erlebnisses
[Musik]
zum beispiel als liebende
weihnachtspyramide oder als rudolf das
rotnasigen rentier
wenn jeder von uns jeden tag nur einen
obdachlosen weihnachtlich dekoriert dann
macht das einkaufen wieder spaß so
schatz haben wir alles
wir müssen noch zu belassen
[Musik]
unser weihnachten soll schöner werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]